[Applauso]
pensate per un attimo al momento della
vostra vita in cui avete avuto più paura
per una separazione per una brutta
diagnosi clinica
un piano di licenziamenti in azienda
pensate a come siete stati capaci di
trasformare quella paura paralizzante
preludio di catastrofe in un'opportunità
trasformarle in energia l'energia che
magari vi ha portato a trovare un altro
amore magari più bello di quello di
prima di fondare una startup senza
aspettare di essere licenziati
oppure di guarire da una malattia o
semplicemente approfittarne per vivere
più intensamente la vita che avete
Come mi piacerebbe che oggi guardassimo
i cambiamenti climatici così
li guardasse ma guardando tutta la paura
che i cambiamenti che il cambiamento
climatico le sue conseguenze ci fanno e
trasformassimo questa paura in energia
per costruire il futuro in particolare
dei nostri bambini
vi chiedo di pensare ad un'immagine che
associate
al cambiamento climatico
è molto probabile che sia qualcosa di
simile Questi sono i primi risultati che
Google restituisce quando li si cerca
Io invece ve ne propongo un'altra a cui
immagino che pochi di voi abbiano
pensato Scusate la voce
questa
è un'immagine forte
che immagino che pochi di voi abbiano
abbinato al cambiamento climatico
Secondo i dati dell'ONU sono dall'inizio
della pandemia sono stati i 45 milioni i
bambini che hanno sofferto di
denutrizione e ben 149 milioni che hanno
sofferto delle conseguenze dell'assenza
di nutritivi essenziali all'interno
della loro dieta In totale sono più di
due miliardi per l'esattezza 2 3
le persone che nel mondo soffrono di
insicurezza lamentare cioè diciamo che
non hanno certezza di poter mangiare
sempre
cosa c'entra questo col cambiamento
climatico Mi direte voi Siamo qui per
parlare esattamente di questo di come ci
sia un legame profondo Tra gli effetti
del cambiamento climatico la capacità di
resilienza del sistema produttivo
agricolo e la sicurezza alimentare cioè
il diritto all'accesso al cibo da parte
di tutti
quando pensiamo al cambiamento climatico
molto probabilmente pensiamo a questo
l'immagine di un buco nero come se il
cambiamento climatico fosse qualcosa che
impatta luoghi lontani persone che non
incontreremo mai tutto sommato qualcosa
per fortuna sufficientemente lontano da
noi dal non dovercelo preoccupare troppo
e questo è un po' il limite il limite
forse la difesa che gli uomini attivano
noi uomini attiviamo per difenderci
dalle cose che un po' ci spaventano le
teniamo lontane e se volete Questo è un
grande e un grande limite allo sviluppo
di una coscienza individuale e
collettiva ambientale
e io vi faccio una domanda un po'
provocatoria siamo sicuri che sia così
lontano questo cambiamento climatico se
vi dicessi che il cambiamento climatico
potrebbe entrare nelle nostre case
arrivi dando addirittura a minacciare
quello che di più caro abbiamo sulle
nostre bambini in acciaio di non di
determinare una difficoltà di accesso al
cibo persino per loro
nel 2050 si stima che saranno c'è 10
Milioni miliardi le persone che dovremmo
sfamare
una bella sfida
una sfida a cui sono chiamati oggi
500 milioni di Agricoltori nel mondo
tanti Eh Peccato che tra questi sono
l'1%, sia strutturato in forma di
impresa In sostanza abbiamo una
pattuglia abbastanza piccola per 10
miliardi di persone
di imprenditori agricoli che
rappresentano un po' il nostro plotone
la nostra squadra speciale di sicurezza
alimentare che combatte ogni giorno
contro gli effetti e il cambiamento
climatico cercando di produrre
nonostante per esempio un grande nemico
che quello della siccità ne sentite
parlare ogni giorno in questo periodo
i nostri campi i nostri allevamenti
tutti abbiamo Abbiamo sete sempre più
sete pensiamo al riso a proposito di
piatto per i bimbi il riso è un alimento
che abbiamo sempre considerato parte
della nostra alimentazione che abbiamo
completamente per scontato
purtroppo devo dirvi che il riso non è
così scontato perché le falde acquifere
vanno e stress Già all'inizio dell'anno
il livello dei fiumi e dei Laghi è
sempre più basso gli eventi
meteorologici
eccezionali sono sempre più frequenti e
complice la fragilità idrogeologica del
nostro paese ci vuol poco anche un
minuto per distruggere colture che sono
lì da anni e anni e anni
l'agricoltura si trova davanti a tutto
questo e il cambiamento climatico non lo
considera un concetto etico di Woody
scooter un concetto lontano lo vive
sulla sua pelle lo tocca con le sue mani
lo guarda con i suoi occhi ogni giorno
ogni giorno in azienda e fa quello che
ha sempre fatto che in fondo ha sempre
fatto l'uomo si adatta si ingegna evolve
l'innovazione in agricoltura Scusate ho
sbagliato l'innovazione in agricoltura
non è una non è un'utopia è un è un
fatto abbiamo l'innovazione in
agricoltura significato rivoluzione
meccanica pensate quanto questi
attrezzini hanno cambiato i processi
produttivi
e genetica che ha alterato la
composizione della diciamo la resistenza
stessa delle piante agli eventi avversi
ed è rivoluzione digitale oggi e la
rivoluzione digitale non è un non è un
concetto anche questa astratto in realtà
per molte imprese agricole per le più
dimensionate naturalmente
e consente di preservare il patrimonio
di ogni azienda in termini di
produttività
consente di esaltare quella produttiva
produttività anche attraverso il riuso
delle acque reflue attraverso l'utilizzo
degli scarti di produzione in un'ottica
di economia circolare anche di questo
penso che avete sentito parlare tanto
l'agricoltura attraverso l'innovazione
cattura la CO2 attraverso il Carbon
farping e rende attraverso la genetica
le piante più resistenti agli attacchi
parassitari
e alla mancanza d'acqua e la stessa
mancanza d'acqua riesce a gestirla
perché la digitalizzazione ci consente
di avere sistemi estremamente
sofisticati che ci consentono di
irrigare solo dove e quando serve
perché questo diventi la regola e non
solo l'eccellenza di chi ha la
possibilità di avventurarsi su questa
strada è necessario agire È necessario
una volontà politica e non solo del
nostro paese ma una volontà politica più
ampia come presidente della Repubblica
ha ricordato di recente parlando degli
effetti drammatici dei cambiamenti
climatici Non può essere lo sforzo di un
solo stato a contrastare un evento così
grande è uno sforzo collettivo quello
che si chiede di fare e che non si può
non fare la cosa peggiore che si possa
fare davanti alla paura di rimanere
paralizzati e rimanerne vittima dobbiamo
fare Dobbiamo agire ognuno di voi può
fare delle cose queste le avrete viste
100 volte sono buone pratiche
buone pratiche che devono servire non
tanto ad esser Green cioè un po'
criticamente stucchevolmente ecologici
ambientalisti ma essere grainer cioè
avviarsi in un percorso che è lento e
faticoso di transizione di evoluzione di
crescita che ci porterà fuori da questo
momento
c'è un passaggio che che mi piace molto
ricordare quando abbiamo strade molto
lunghe davanti ci fa un po' paura e
iniziare però ho fatto il primo passo
proprio un pianino la meta sembra sempre
meno lontana allora tra i primi passi
che dobbiamo fare io penso che non ci
sia soltanto
ingegnarci come l'agricoltore in
generale l'uomo ha sempre fatto ma ci
sia anche aprirci
aprirci a quello che il cambiamento
climatico porta e che ci fa che ci può
far paura se lo guardiamo con paura Ma
ci può rappresentare davvero
un'opportunità se la guardiamo con
apertura mentale pensiamo ai flussi
migratori che i cambiamenti climatici
stanno spingendo ai nostri confini ci
fanno paura abbiamo alziamo i muri
ci preoccupiamo Eppure lo dice una
cittadina di una città di mare
dominata da mille da mille culture
diverse
e in effetti è una delle città che ha
prodotto Penso il numero più alto di
Miss Italia perché quell'incrocio di
cultura ha prodotto tanta bellezza
la mescolanza tra le culture non ci deve
spaventare la mescolanza diventa
nuova cultura culinaria per esempio
diventa nuova cultura della moda e può
diventare nuova può diventare nuove
colture quelle colture che oggi noi
consideriamo lontane lontane da noi che
magari a causa complice grazie lo
vogliamo dire al cambiamento climatico
sarebbero praticabili In fin dei conti
in Inghilterra ormai fanno il vino
e quindi per concludere vi invito vi
invito tutti noi e me per prima
a trovare il bello che c'è nella paura e
quel bello è quella capacità di
guardarla in faccia
trasformarla e farla diventare energia
per andare avanti per cambiare per
evolvere e per guardare al futuro dei
nostri figli con occhi meno spaventati
Grazie a tutti
[Applauso]